This is our religion, it is our
way of thinking. When I play, I don't
play.
When I play, I leave my body
so that the energy of my ancestors
can manifest itself physically on
this plane. What I feel for
sport is a lot of love. This is breakfast.  this
is this lunch my life is this since
robert vitales paid me new continues when the
starbucks burger regime of mayáns
airplanes for cold mesoamericano all in
one weeks of less importance
turn on any
game law in armando s leave the document my
name is armando osorio and  I dedicate myself to
spreading the ball game in Mexico and
in other countries. It
is an invasion game where I
have to take the opponent out of his own court
until I get the ball through the
middle of the bottom line that they
have.
I know who I am.
roberts
the ball is made of solid rubber
from a nail tree
the hardest part of this game is the
beginning because you get very
big bruises very big bruises  very big
about three years ago we were four
teams last year I called
all the states we were already eight and right
now we are already 17 states
hello my name is queen maria puig cif and
I dedicate myself to the ball game
this sport is both male
and  feminine and we decided in this
sport to carry it in duality as
our ancestors have not inherited it,
so I feel very happy that
both men and women have
the same ability to play this sport
for me it is very important because it is a
legacy that we leave  to leave our
children to our children to
our children's children the
ultimate goal of this sport is that there is
a contribution from society
for me my biggest dream would be that
these young people could be awarded scholarships to be
able to have another economic level and
have a chance in society
[Music]
when the holy inquisition came it was when they
started to ban this sport if it
hadn't been banned by them today it
's gone  it was the most famous sport than
soccer the ultimate goal of this sport is to be
able to make a professional league what
soccer is like
[Music
] sport is more than just a sport
that is a love for sport
[Music]